you know it's it's very exciting when
you have a constitutional crisis we are
so [ __ ] I'm telling you we are today
Venezuela put us on the tribal advisory
telling you if America was a summer
blockbuster it would be called democracy
endgame if you missed the earlier
installments in this franchise started
with Russia interfere this is the you
know nobody disagrees with this in the
mullet report Russia interfered with our
election in 2008 that was the finding of
that report and this week we found out
that Robert Muller wrote more than one
letter to the Attorney General
wink wink William bar saying why did you
miss characterize what I wrote and bar
responded well the report was my baby my
baby
I thought Republicans were against
killing babies
which Delbar is so far up Trump's ass he
bumped into Hannon
so so bar went before the Senate this
week on Wednesday and the Democrats
looked also happy after is only that
they gave him a good grilling I think
they're missing the big picture
Trump is still president and the big
gotcha was they got bar to commit
perjury which apparently is some
old-timey law about lying being wrong
you know Nancy Pelosi said that's a
crime and I'm going to report it to oh
yeah oh yeah see this is the problem
when the guy who is supposed to be
enforcing the law is the guy who is
breaking the law
yeah the Justice Department had a
deadline this week to provide the
unredacted version of the malla report
that just blew it off because this is
called owning the libs this is all they
care about the lamer the excuse the
better cuz the more we're owned oh the
laymen tête the report over there
because the printer jammed and then they
went to Kinko's but some kid was doing
flyers for his band I mean
and then you know the Attorney General
was himself subpoenaed by the house to
appear yesterday blew that off and
Congress was like you know we both work
for the same country right so legal
experts are now saying that you know
this this is a constitutional crisis the
likes of which we have not seen in three
or four days not showing up what when
did testifying before Congress become
optional its Congress not freshman psych
class and Democrats don't seem to get it
that you know it's in the rules it's not
an argument that works on Donald Trump
you're playing Monopoly with a hyena
when it bites you and shits on the board
saying it's not your turn
doesn't relieve work so the goodness
the good news is Trump finally today sat
down and talked to someone about Russia
gay the bad news is it was a lot amir
Putin I wish that was the joke that's
absolutely true
he usually they just sext each other but
[Applause]
today they actually got on the phone for
an hour the few know the famous red
phone a hotline to Moscow well now it's
a pink princess phone you know maybe it
would help if Democrats just changed
their names to more Russian sounding
names may be probably more willing to
talk to Adam Schiff ski and Nancy Pelosi
Mitch as if all that is not enough to
give me a coronary this week Hillary
Clinton is stealing my act I'm watching
Rachel Maddow the other day
and this is what you said China if
you're listening why don't you get
Trump's tax returns okay here's our show
from last August and since we now accept
that it's okay to merge your party with
a foreign power I'd like to be the first
member of the resistance to say China if
you're listening
I hope you can find Donald Trump's tax
returns
[Music]
what if lenses real-time with crooked
Hillary Heather if you wanted material
you should have asked me before the
election
you